لا انا هنا اريد ان اوضح مساله كبيره جدا
انه في
المرحله السابقه كانت هناك العديد من
الشخصيات التي
[موسيقى]
ليس لديها اي رخصه قانونيه او بعض
الصحافيين بين ظفرين الذين هم
ليس لديهم بطاقه مهنيه بل هم فقط مرسلين
من بعض
القنوات الغير ملخص الغير ملخص لها من اجل
تخطيط اعمال البرلمان
وفوجئنا في ذلك الوقت بالعديد من الاشباه
الاعلاميين الذين يحاولون السيد في المياه
العكره
نعم يعني هناك اعلاميين ببطاقه محترفه
وهناك بعض
هؤلاء الاشباح
هم حتى معناها بعض الملحقين في البرلمان
او بعض
الصحف
سيد فاطمه وانت يعني جئت جئت يمكن بتصويت
شعبي في مناخ من الحريه والديمقراطيه في
تونس غير المسبوقه بعد الثوره عكس ما كانت
عليه
تعودوني الى نفس الحاله بالقامه بالاخفاء
بابعاد الاعلام لا يتفق ابدا مع هذا
النموذج السياسي المطلوب
نحن لم نبعد الاعلان نحن بعد فتره كبيره
انه البرلمان كان مغلقا
وكانت معناها عندنا بعض الايام فقط من اجل
انه يتم التحذير للجنس الافتتاحيه لم يكن
لنا الوقت الكافي للتثبت من كل الرخص
القوانين القانونيه للاعلاميين ليس لنا
اداره
لذلك وغيرها لانه في فتره استثنائيه فقمنا
بقرار استثنائي استثنائي فقط للجلسه
الاستفتاحيه قبل ان ننظم علاقه المجلس
النواب بالاعلام وذلك فقط للجلسه
الافتتاحيه قمنا بالبث المباشر لم نغطي اي
شيء لم نخفي اي شيء البث المباشر كان
موجود فقط هو موجود للوسائل الاعلاميه
العام العموميه اما بالنسبه للوسائل
الاعلام الخاصه
سامحني لحظه فقمنا
اليوم بعد بعد ان
قمنا باشغال لجنه النظام الداخلي قمنا
برسم كل الضوابط وموجود في النظام الداخلي
للمجلس انه التغطيه الاعلاميه الصحفيه
المكتوبه والمرئيه وغيرها ستقوم بالبث
المباشر في كل الجلسات واللجان وهذا حق من
حقوقها لاننا لا نخفي شيئا فقط ذلك كان
للجلسه الافتتاحيه قبل ان تبدا العامل
المش